字幕提供
我們喜歡做的
是在大顆度的互換
如果有這個位置
大顆度的互換區域
等待小顆度
小顆度的破底翻
大互換區等小破底翻
这个这样子的整体结果就会是很棒的
那你说这里一定永远都会是长破底翻的样子吗?
不一定,他说不定就像这样子,几根下不去
然后可能就上去了,他也不见得会真的打出什么东西来
有时候有,有时候没有,但是重点就在于
我们喜欢打这一段
走上去,整理,走下来
就是五等的破底翻
所以你看我们的五等
在这个地方我们是画破底翻的样子
那你说这里要不要等互换
可不可以
可以啊
你可以在大互换区
也来等个小互换
注意看我的话
小互换可能就是下来
整理整理整理上来
那这个框框内
是不是互换
是吗
对吧
那你说如果這樣子看是不是破底翻這樣子看是不是破底翻也是
我要繼續畫囉
如果下來然後轉到這邊
然後這個互換
這個我會完全放掉
因為這整件事情
這整件事情
它的这个关键边缘
它必须要发生在
要发生在这里
它不能发生在其他太高的位置
这种呼唤也不要
所以其实
你要在这种边界等呼唤
你说这里
有没有可能
例如说像这个地方
如果有
这是不是叫小呼唤
而是同时间
它也是小破底翻的概念
有没有
等你看到最后
练到最后
呼唤也好
破底翻也好
这个边界就会越来越模糊
因为到最后就只会剩下下不去的迹象
因为你已经看久了
你很熟悉
下不去的迹象就这几种而已
那可能有时候是用图形的方式让你看得出来
有时候是用下引线的方式让你看出来
有时候是用互换的方式
但是这些的根本的意义
都是在告诉你市场的力道在这里有人在用
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive